hey i'm back with a note on speed fan
for windows uh this is for windows vista
i downloaded and installed speedfan
right
uh i have rivatuner
here and i've run it it's okay
but speed fan i have to show you guys on
a laptop i'm going to finish up
reviewing my laptop soon it's an hp
pavilion dv7 t
and
i have to tell you it does not work on
most laptops i've added on my friend's
laptop i've tried it on this laptop
the only thing it recognizes is the
temperatures
in the readings it only recognizes the
temperatures and the course there's
nothing down here down here down here
there's nothing here there's no options
here you can only configure certain
things i mean
it's really really just lifeless on a
laptop
so uh it's running at 2.2 gigahertz
right as i opened it whatever
um
yeah it's just really it's not as full
featured look at that it's all empty
it's completely empty
because it's running on a laptop now if
you look on other youtube videos
on a desktop it runs fine it has all the
fan info
it has all the temperatures
it has all the editing it has all the
like um overclocking well actually
that's not even overclocking but it's
just
i just have to it doesn't work well on a
laptop so um if you're planning on using
a fan controller i actually just
download i actually just ordered
um from newegg.com
a
the crime lx mzxt uh so i'll just show
you it
it is a laptop cooler obviously i have a
17 inch laptop so i
ordered this
i don't know if i can do a review and i
have to get a camera so i can do reviews
on this thing
but 60 70 bucks i got it from newegg.com
that's the link i clicked
that is it
it is just sweet
i won't
whatever
it's it's really nice uh it's
better i'd say than software to cool
your computer
so
thanks for watching that was just a
short note on
uh your fan speeds
cool
you